we are on overtime barbara Lee are you
satisfied with how the Democratic party
platform came out I heard Bernie lost on
everything Bernie did not lose on
everything I'm actually an admission of
the jacket I'm a member of the drafting
committee of the platform and I would
say the negotiations between senator
Clinton Secretary of State Clinton and
senator Sanders views points of views
the negotiations went very well we got
into the platform abolishing the death
penalty decriminalization of marijuana
we yes the bladder bagel what about
carbon tax burning no and I not
supported the amendment for carbon tax
even though I was not a Sanders
appointee whenever I work taking down a
$15 an hour minimum wage yes that's in
the platform also when you look at yeah
health care is a human right we didn't
get Medicare anyway delegate I have not
endorsed either I'm a super delegate by
superderek oh yeah I'm not endorsing so
you are an available super delegate van
der then I'm yelling word i scrapper
trying to make the platform
become what the American people want to
see I feel era
Landers are doing quite a fine job in
moving the platform over everyone can
embrace it and campaign on it and beat
them my phone is ringing off the hook
it's not Jim Gaffigan how do you plan to
keep your five children entertained when
you go on tour with them this summer
leave them with me I love kids
well now that pot is legal um no it's
iPads swimming pools right okay so you
will you take your kit you take your
kids on the road on your we do we go on
a tour bus
and we show a night and how many rooms
you have to get in the motel we get to
connecting ones and you know it's chaos
but it's fun I mean it's exhaustive
words right out of my mouth you should
come along I can't wait
absolutely
the clue kids how old is the oldest now
I have no idea well twelve ten seven
five three
oh my so you job what are you done now
I don't know that's right Catholic up to
God no it's I mean it's I know that's
the role that you think that like Jesus
is telling us that but I'm in a world
and to help says look I do like ten
percent of the work my wife I love
children there's not a single child that
I would trade back in so if there's
another one there's another one ten
percent of the work you talking about
your sex life yeah
Gary John I mean I didn't make up on it
that way but yeah sure
kind of fits right yeah Gary Johnson do
you have a comprehensive plan to combat
climate change well I think follow that
I have a comprehensive plan no I do
believe climate change is man-made I do
believe that the free market has really
taken it - Cole Cole Cole has been
bankrupted and not because of the free
market that's because Obama and the EPA
no Cole is selling at an all-time low
and even lower than it the sales price
for Cole is natural gas
so no new plants that didn't happen
because of the free market well we're
demanding less carbon emission as
consumers and the price of coal like I
say as low as it is is even natural gas
is even lower so no new plants are going
to be built so you think the free market
can handle the problem of global warming
I think that we as consumers are
demanding less carbon emission and we're
going to be that's that's sort of
inherently weird right like you have a
problem that was caused by the
Industrial Revolution and you're a
libertarian so you want then the thing
that caused it magically uncaused it or
solve it like what other it can you what
other example has ever
that happen oh if you if you look at the
model for the future I think the model
for the future is Tesla look wait you
got solar panels on the roof your story
they're an example of like a public
security or social problem that's been
solved by its cause you know and yeah
just stuff you're saying is just right
over the top of my head short well it
just seems conscious your question no I
think it's an excellent question and I
you know I honestly wish the Libertarian
Party sounded less like the Republican
Party on that issue which to me is the
most important I mean it you know
well we're weird like to I'm aboard for
this is the percent of the world's
population thirty-seven percent of the
coal load are the electrical load right
now is coming from coal no new coal
plants are gonna be built we're gonna
significantly reduce co2 emission in
this country well I hope Miami is still
here when we do um Louise what who do
you think will succeed David Cameron his
prime minister now that nobody else
wants it Oh quite a lot of people wanted
Boris Johnson well who's gonna be the
guy out he's he's very called still in
six so I think it'll be a guy called
like a while what did that happen
probably because Boris was
insufficiently committed to actually
taking us out of brexit yeah I think he
was having a little bit of a little bit
of a doubt yeah we think it was a little
bit lukewarm so maybe a guy called
Michael Gove or a woman called Andrea
led some my Dark Horse best either one
of those two but it's gonna be somebody
that's fully committed to brexit because
we're all in for free trade we like the
free mark and who's gonna end up on Game
of Thrones
we would we would we would have
nominated Donald Trump if we could have
caught him while he was in Scotland but
he made a quick getaway so that that's a
good you watch Game of Thrones like
yours that's not too violent and too
dirty and to mean I'm not making my
three-year-old watch it right having
them watch Ramsay Bolton shut up the
guys need this but uh yeah that's a we
watch that I mean what kids what what
what's the most out there show you you
can handle that I can handle well yeah
well I mean well I don't want to hear
any strong language bill I mean yeah I
mean we'll watch we'll watch everything
actually I let my 10 and 12 year old
watch Walking Dead which is pretty
ridiculous but right they love the
stories okay got the right answer yet no
there are no wrong answers here so March
of stories in Catholicism I'm a Catholic
too so yeah well we're raised with
really with quite a lot of torture born
in in the religion people getting
crushed to death by stones and burnt
alive and how about tongues but you know
who that's torture that's yeah yeah
that's right that's pretty much
everywhere so I mean we actually were
first on Game of Thrones we should sue
for royalties I think right you know Mel
Gibson is making a sequel to Passion of
the Christ
Wow you didn't know that I didn't I mean
it's not like I would know I mean I'm
just Catholic I'm not a spokesman
actually I'm the only comedian who
believes in God it's like being an
Colbert I know nothing right okay you
know what though
I was raised a Catholic in the Catholic
Church I'm not a Catholic anymore but it
was the social justice message of the
Bible and of Jesus Christ and the
revolutionary nature of his life that
really died you know encouraged me to be
a Catholic and that was my reason for us
world wide actually because I could not
I could not handle the captions I was
emotional no no on women on women ah you
know on divorce on all of the issues
that oppressed people and especially
women I just couldn't handle it and so
that's why I had to go like look man I
did States has done horrible things why
don't you leave the United States yeah
that's sort of I'm gonna stay here and
try to help make it better
yes I wasn't going to do that with this
religion because there many other
religions I could I know I know I'm just
messing but your your democracy like
comparisons weird because the United
States says those things and people
actively oppose it in a religion it's
one truth that you're subscribing to
it's different not exactly I'm not
development or dummy I notice the
prosecutor names out your where was this
during the show
all right thank you everybody
you